hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast making the most of your
mouse model with bead based multiplexing
I'm Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by Luminex for more
information on our sponsor please visit
luminex Corp comm now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
answer a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenter dr. Daniel brown Schweich
proteomics field applications scientist
leader at bio-rad laboratories dr.
Daniel Braunschweig received his PhD in
immunology from the University of
California Davis studying the role of
the immune system in autism he
subsequently published more than 15
peer-reviewed articles on the interface
between neuro development and immunology
within emphasis on emerging immunoassay
techniques
dr. Braunschweig has held a variety of
positions in the biotechnology field and
currently leads a team of field
applications scientists focused on
assisting researchers with protein
purification and immunoassays for a
complete biography on dr. Braunschweig
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. Braunschweig you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much Judy we'll get
started now discussing bead based
multiplexing technology using mouse
models the agenda for today is to
discuss different uses for mouse models
and where they're most relevant some
insights they can be gained from their
use as well as limitations that people
should be aware of when using mouse
models and we'll discuss the xMAP
platform for use in mouse models various
diseases when planning experiments there
are a variety of considerations that are
quite important when using mouse models
we'll take a look at some of those and
we'll finish by looking at some of the
attributes of assays that will make them
optimal for mouse experiments so here we
go now before we get started I want to
frame this conversation in the context
of Koch's postulates these are basically
the criteria that were established quite
a while ago to identify the causative
agents and disease these are widely
known and you know ultimately for
microorganisms that cause disease they
should be found in a disease organism
they should be able to be isolated and
then those microorganisms when cultured
to introduce the disease into an
otherwise healthy organism and then
later be reactivated as well and broadly
speaking these postulates are true
although over time numerous exceptions
to these postulates have arisen and I
think this is a good perspective to take
when considering the use of mouse models
in biomedical research because in many
regards they do represent disease states
well as they apply to humans but there
are many exceptions to that and it's
those exceptions that are really
critical to be cognizant of when
selecting the appropriate mouse model as
well as the appropriate tools for
analyzing that model so moving forward
mouse models are very widely used
essentially all pharmaceutical
development relies heavily on mouse
models during R&D stages particularly an
emerging area in pharmaceutical research
our immunotherapies and and cell and
gene therapies where rather than having
a drug that directly
pihl's a micro disease-causing
microorganisms or cures of disease
there's a lot of effort underway now to
modulate the human immune system in a
way that it can actually effectively
clear disease or to change using gene
manipulation to change cells of the host
individual to better be able to address
disease so there are a lot of
immunodeficient mice that are used in
this case for hosting human cells or
human tissues to identify cures for
these diseases and this is this is a
major area of mouse model use currency
and importantly basically in support of
the fact that essentially all
pharmaceuticals are developed these days
using mouse models this is a rapidly
growing industry and currently
represents approximately two billion
dollars spent annually only on the mouse
models and their analysis in
pharmaceutical Rd it's a quite a large
business and it is growing and this of
course is not to mention the extensive
use of mouse models and academic
research with the goal of just
characterizing through these dates now
mouse models bring with them many pros
and cons so the many insights that can
be gained from using them so we'll take
a look at a few of those certainly in
the context of diseases that are either
caused by or who has pervaded by certain
genetic conditions knockout strains of
mice for easily relatively easily
created and widely available these days
from commercial sources so this way
individual genes can be analyzed for
their impact on the disease state in
general during pharmaceutical
development in Rd mouse model data is
used by by pharmaceutical companies who
are submitting to the FDA and is
accepted generally by them when used
appropriately
fortunately a lot of developments has
been made in the area of assays for
determining the response of a mouse
model to a very to a disease state or a
treatment and so there's a quite a wide
range of acetate content available to
interrogate mouse models on the other
hand there are some limitations that are
really important to keep in mind as you
develop a mouse model for your work in
some cases the disease State or the
progression of the disease can be
unclear in the mouse model and this is
particularly true in the early stages of
a disease and that's oftentimes a point
where it is very important to understand
the beginning of the disease and I must
be able to measure accurately the early
stages of the disease and there are also
a lot of ways that people approach the
experimental design using mouse models
and different ways that the data are
interpreted and it's quite important to
maintain consistency with this in order
for the data to be useful and of course
there are numerous strains of mice and
we'll see later this presentation that
the impact of the age of the mouse or
the tissue that's used can be quite
significant in the results the one gets
when looking for various immune factors
in these legs and the last thing is that
the development of a mouse doesn't
perfectly parallel that of humans and
this is particularly true when you're
looking at developmental disorders that
the stages of development are not
exactly the same and so it's important
to keep that in mind when looking at the
impact of the mouse model the impact of
the disease on the mouse model now of
course the biggest con and one of the
biggest challenges that researchers face
when using mouse models is their small
size which greatly limits the available
sample from each Mouse so based on that
looking at the small size of this now so
take a look at what actually is
available from a mouse model so an adult
Mouse has approximately 1.5 millimeters
in whole blood from that one can derive
approximately 500 microliters of serum
were used in assays
for genotyping emmaus to determine to
determine the genotype or to mark the
mouse for poor future work there's
approximately two to three millimeters
of an ear punch that can be taken or the
tip of a tail for that work the brain of
a mouse is approximately one gram so
when you start to look at individual
brain regions it can be difficult to do
those two sections and to derive
sufficient tissue for all the analysis
that's necessary and in general when you
look at the rest of the tissues in the
mouse you're looking at milligram
quantities of lymph nodes or spleen
heart liver etc so as people need to
understand the impact of treatments on
their disease for example and look at
liver toxicity which is an important
marker you know the amount of tissue
available can be a limitation so if you
want to sufficiently interrogate a mouse
model there are some critical
characteristics of the platform that
you're going to use so let's talk about
that here of course we mentioned that
there is relatively little sample
available from the mouse and so we want
to make sure that the platform is able
to provide as much data as possible with
a small sample volume we do need to make
sure that the assay is quite sensitive
because as we mentioned before the early
stages of a disease are the place where
an intervention oftentimes is most
effective so to be able to identify
those earliest stages is quite important
the results that you get need to be
comprehensive these days the diseases
that remain to be solved are often
multifactorial and the treatments the
efficacy of a treatment is measured not
by a single single outcome but the sum
total of a variety of factors so it's
important to be able to get all of those
data with one platform and of course
it's very important that the data is
highly reproducible so that it is
convincing to the regulatory authorities
it would be helpful if all of this could
be achieved with a cost-effective
platform and the xMAP platform I think
really effectively achieves all of these
needs
here so we take a little bit a brief
look at how the xMAP platform works and
how the assays are constructed these are
be based multiplex assays similar to an
Eliza in concept the beads are
fluorescently labeled and each bead has
a different spectral address and to
these beads or conjugated capture
antibodies and so these are put into a
96-well plate or a 384-well plate and
the first step is to simply dispense the
beads and these beads would have capture
antibodies for all of the different
analytes that one is interested in
analyzing and so those are put into the
plate and washed two times and at that
point sample is added so when the sample
contains the analytes that the capture
antibodies on the beads recognizes it
will bind the beads will bind to that
analyte and the rest of the unbound
material is subsequently washed off with
three wash steps afterwards a biotin
elated detection antibody specific for a
different epitope on the same analyte is
added and this yields a sandwich
immunoassay that's highly specific
because it requires the simultaneous
binding at two different antibodies in
order to get a signal so that detection
antibody is biotin elated which will
then enable our downstream detection of
the analyte quantity using a
streptavidin echo erythroid marker the
streptavidin binds to the biotin elated
detection antibodies and the fico
birthright of the fluorescent reporter
guy and the fluorescence output is
measured using a laser based fluidic
system and each of the beads is
individually analyzed characterized
refer to as sorted here the fluorescent
sorting determines which analyte is
being measured and the relative amount
of psychometric fluorescence allows one
to plot a standard curve yielding a
relative concentration measurement for
that analyte in that sample
so when you perform an assay like this
and you get this data it's also really
important to consider the overall
experiment that you're that you're
running here so we just finished
discussing how the platform works and
that samples are added and you can get a
multiplex measurement of a variety of
factors often times the mutant factors
cytokines chemokines growth factors
various things you would want a
comprehensive picture within a single
sample and what we're going to look at
now is after acquiring that data in
order to analyze it properly it's
critical that the experiment was
designed in a way that will facilitate
that analysis so I've got an example
right here of a situation where age was
a factor that was compared is a response
to influenza infection in a mouse model
and while this is a relatively large age
difference the adult mice are 12 to 16
weeks of age versus the aging mice which
are 72 to 76 weeks of age what we see
here is the impact just of age in
otherwise a well controlled experiment
where the strain of mouse is exactly the
same they were they were administered
exactly the same strain of influenza
virus timing was exactly the same and
what we see is that based on simply
based on age there is a significant
change in the rate of cytokine response
and for some cytokines a change in the
magnitude of that response and it goes
both ways what we see here is that in
some cases for some inflammatory markers
you see a more rapid increase in the
response among the age of mice for
example in Ganapathy
in other cases in io6 used simply see a
delayed response of the cytokine
production in the older group of mice
and in all of these cases and in many
other cases that are in this publication
the differences between the two age
groups were highly significant so it's
really important to among other things
control for the age of the animals that
you're using your mouse experiments and
to make sure that they accurately
reflect
the disease that you're studying so in
addition to age let's take a little bit
take a brief look at the impact of the
different tissue that you might look at
in in the level of chemokines you might
be assessing so these data that we're
showing here are composite data from a
panel of 33 chemokines looking at all
the constant levels of these chemokines
across a variety of tissues from a mouse
at two different age points so the age
difference in this case is not as great
as that that we saw in the previous
slide we're looking at the difference
between three week old mice and ton ten
month old mice we're looking at a
variety of tissues on the low end you
can see in brain and in kidney you have
relatively low levels of these
chemokines then from an immunologic
perspective that's not surprising
these are tissues that are not generally
attracting a significant response of
immune cells in healthy mice where as in
plasma where you have most of the
circulation of immune cells occurring
you see relatively higher levels so it's
critical that you're comparing
appropriate tissue or sample sources
when trying to draw conclusions that
those are selected based on the model
that you're using now in addition to the
age differences that we saw on the last
couple of slides it's really important
to just look at it simply the tissue
differences and the correct tissue is
chosen for the work we doing now these
are sort of bulk tissues here we have
liver kidney intestine and many
experiments it's critical to find even
more more specific sub regions of
tissues to look at the impact either the
disease or the treatment and so the
consistency in sample extraction and
preparation is really critical and if it
is just a small region of a tissue that
is going to yield the results that you
need it's really important that there is
good consistency in that sample
acquisition
now shifting a little bit from the
experimental design considerations let's
take a look at the key asset attributes
that we need so we looked previously at
the platform and the characteristics and
the platforms that are really important
and impactful for successful mouse model
research the assets health also plays a
major role and so looking at what we're
looking at here on this slide is a
standard curve from an X map based
experiment and this standard curve is
what's used to determine the
concentration of each of the analytes
within the sample and just to orient you
to what we're seeing on the screen here
along the x-axis we have the
concentration in Pico grams per mil and
along the y axis we have the
fluorescence intensity remember we spoke
about the fico enricher and reporter
molecule that's found to the detection
antibody and that is the fluorescence of
that it's proportional to the quantity
of the analyte present and so that can
be plotted with a standard curve using
standard material and known
concentrations to then yield in this
case a an eight-point standard curve
showing the concentrations of those
standard curve points those are these
square square boxes along the curve in
parentheses we see the percent recovery
and - those are those are a percentage
expression of how close the measured
value of the standard curve point is to
the expected value and a hundred percent
is ideal for that on the lower right
corner you see the the acronym ll OQ and
that is referring to the lower limit of
quantitation so within the range of the
standard curve that is the lowest
concentration can be detected and in
this case it's a bit less than 1
picogram per mil and in the upper left
corner we see the upper limit of
quantitation and so that should be the
high end of the standard curve and along
the curve you can see a series of green
triangles and those are the samples
and so looking at a standard curve like
this the key what you're looking for in
a standard program is a large large
dynamic range as well as excellent
low-end sensitive and those two things
will then yield results and primarily
quantitative results for most samples
and enable the researcher to distinguish
between healthy samples which often
times for these markers have very low
levels of expression versus disease
samples or treated samples which can
have much higher levels and to have both
the healthy end of these samples in
range is quite important for a
successful assayed
when it's possible to get both the
healthy and diseased samples
quantitatively measured within the same
standard curve the statistical analysis
necessary downstream is much easier
now in addition to being able to
identify the concentration of all of
your samples another big benefit of a
comprehensive assay is the ability to
profile an entire signaling pathway and
so frequently this technology is used
for looking at cytokines and chemokines
because the immune system functions
through a variety of signaling molecules
and messengers and no one of them paint
a clearer picture of exactly what is
happening in addition to those
phosphoproteins cell signaling Cascades
are quite important as well until on the
left we see an example of the migration
of immune cells through the airway
epithelium in the various cytokines and
signaling molecules that influence cell
migration and all of those can be
measured in a single well with the same
width with one sample at the same time
and on the right we see the EGF
signaling cascade and the various
downstream mediators that are
phosphoproteins that can be impacted in
that signaling cascade and an example of
a pharmaceutical static Samad that
blocks that signaling and thus blocks
downstream phosphorylation of that
cascade and using a multiplex platform
like this you can actually look at each
of the possible proteins along those
Cascades to determine exactly where the
drug or treatment you're administering
has its impact
so in summary with the key assay
attributes it's really important that
you are able to not only get accurate
and comprehensive data from each
individual sample but the throughput of
samples is amenable to automation I mean
these days it's important to have many
replicates of your model and to be able
to analyze those data quite quickly so
the benefit of being able to look at
data in both the three 296 as well as a
384 well plate format assists with
sample throughput and being able to use
a variety of sample input types and have
compatible reagents as well as provide
the data that would provide data very
quickly that would otherwise
a lot of time to acquire using a non
multiplex approach one other benefit of
doing these analysis in a multiplex
format is that it greatly minimizes the
variability if each of the analyzed was
assayed independently small variations
in timing can impact the reproducibility
of experiments and that's effectively
eliminated in this multiplex platform so
when you're considering multiplex acids
it's really important to make sure that
the vendor that you're considering
provides sufficient data to to determine
to determine that this assay will meet
your experimental needs we discussed the
lower and upper limits of quantitation
when we're looking at the standard curve
and the working range the broad dynamic
range that's necessary in addition to
those another term that is frequently
used as the limit of detection and it's
important to distinguish the limit of
detection from the lower limit of
quantitation limits of detection refer
only to the variation of background and
is typically defined as two standard
deviations above the background and
that's sufficient to determine that a
sample is different from background but
it's not not sufficient to determine
whether what the actual concentration of
that sample is
the inter and assays TB is another
really important characteristic as well
as sample validation so looking at the
performance of the assay and determining
that samples themselves can actually be
measured accurately with the assay is
really another important feature as well
and these last two linearity and
parallelism are further tests to
determine the robustness of the assay
essentially demonstrating that as a
sample is further diluted it continues
to provide the same results and put
those results are the same regardless of
the sample type that is used
now stepping back a little bit we have
been focusing primarily on proteins
looking at the the multiplex assays for
different proteins is critical we know
that these signaling molecules are the
primary drivers that are actually doing
the work within cells but when you step
back you look at looking at the gene
expression is typically what people have
done in the past and what is still a
very important thing to understand what
genes are involved in various pathways
and then looking at the big picture of
the organism it's really the physiology
that is driving us to investigate
diseases a disease is important to
research when the impact is the term is
seen through its physiologic impacts so
protein levels fit squarely between
these things and it's important to
recognize the value of looking at both
the gene expression data as well as the
physiologic data in conjunction with
protein levels so I want to provide you
with a little bit of information that
may not be widely recognized here
because it's been historically there's
been a lot of effort put on looking at
gene expression levels for a lot of
signaling molecules and gene expression
sometimes does Prak well with protein
levels but not always so let's take a
look at an experiment that involved
looking at a mouse brain inflammation
model and terminan both using a cue PCR
technique as well as bio flex technology
whether the gene expression profiles
matched protein levels using a 33 Plex
Mouse chemokine panel the researchers
looked at a variety of signaling
molecules and immune systems of these
mice and particularly in mouse brain
information both with what with the
protein levels as well as the gene
expression and determined that
approximately three-quarters 73 percent
of the analytes looked at tracked
similarly in messenger RNA levels and
using the Q PCR
versus protein levels but a bit more
than a quarter diverged significantly
from between the gene and protein levels
we can see that list right here
the chemokines in red tracked similarly
between gene and proteins and those in
black were different and so it's quite
important to remember that RNA and the
gene expression is not a proxy for
protein expression they're both
important and they can both provide
different information particularly when
the information about regulation of gene
transcription is important or the
persistence of proteins is relevant and
in many disease states it is so thank
you very much for your attention with
this and leave you with this left last
slide looking at a mouse model and and
now I'm open to taking any questions
thank you dr. Brown Frank for your
informative presentation
we will now start live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer a question box located on
the far left of your screen well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is what is it about Luminex
technology that enables such a higher
degree of multiplexing than other
technologies that's a good question yeah
we spoke a little bit about earlier in
the presentation the colored beads of
fluorescent by Chris fears that
underlies Illumina technology and the
benefit of using these fluorescent
microspheres is that up to 500 different
spectral addresses can be determined
with these with with the dyeing within
the microspheres and therefore you can
have up to a 500 Plex assay until when
compared with technologies that involve
spots on the bottom of a well or a Eliza
or Western blotting the throughput is
dramatically higher because of the
microspheres their small size their
ability to be bound with different
detection antibodies different capture
antibodies and then ultimately different
detection antibodies so the Plex level
because of the bead base of linux
technology is far superior to most other
proteomics tools available today thank
you
next one is how do you prepare tissues
Forex map assays oh that is a good
question and preparing tissues for
x-naught assays there isn't a single
answer that it that solves that and one
important guiding principle in it is
that it's critical to determine a good
tissue preparation strategy and then
stick with that throughout all of one's
experiments typically mild detergents
would be used to disrupt tissues but
this can vary dramatically based on the
based on how easy it is to disrupt the
tissue and so broadly speaking using
what is often referred to as a rip of
buffer is a reasonable place to start
various vendors have lysis kits that are
welded well suited for this technology
and so some amount of experimentation
needs to occur prior to determine the
optimal protocol for tissue preparation
but invariably this will involve some
amount of protease and phosphatase
inhibition as well as solubilizing the
proteins and if they are membrane bound
proteins to use appropriate detergents
for that and generally to keep the
detergent concentration relatively low
in order to not disrupt antibody binding
during the assay okay we have time for
one more question what would cause an
analyte to not be detectable within an
assay
yeah so typically with a well-structured
a say the main reason for an analyte to
not be detectable would simply be
because the concentration of the analyte
in the sample is too low as below the
lower limit of quantitation or the limit
of detection you're looking at and so
that can occur in many cases
physiologically many of the analytes
that are interesting to look at occur at
very low concentrations in healthy
individuals and our upgrade up graduated
massively in the case of disease and so
an analyte might not be detected in all
healthy samples that's a pretty normal
thing in fact that's something that is
physiologically favorable because when
you have an it when you have an analyte
that is capable of eliciting a really
strong recruitment of immune cells or
leading to dramatic infection it's
really important to that analyte exists
at a negligible if any level during
normal physiology but in so in cases
where low levels are important to look
at as I mentioned before for example at
the early stages and disease it's really
critical to have an assay whose lower
limit of quantitation is as low as
possible or low enough to sufficiently
detect the analyte we are looking for so
again when you're taking a look through
commercial vendors for a things it's
really important to make sure you have
information about the lower limit of
quantitation and some understanding of
what your model what you would predict
in your model would have in terms of
concentrations of those analytes to best
guide you [ __ ] well thank you again
dr. Braunschweig do you have any final
comments for our audience yeah I really
appreciate you listening and being
engaged through this presentation and
wish wish you all the best in the work
you're doing ultimately these mouse
models are used to solve some of the
most challenging diseases that afflict
humans and it's really quite important
work so I I wish everybody listening the
greatest success with their efforts
thank you before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting question
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to thank dr. Braunschweig for his
time today and his important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor Luminex for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through june of
2019 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye